i feel like a really bad cat mom
this is chester
we have him leash trained i think that
because we trained him on the leash and
we did it pretty quickly that we should
be able to train him to use a toilet i
think that it's going to be really good
because our entire bathroom is full of
litter
[Music]
it's like an actual litter box that goes
on the toilet it uses a proven
disappearing litter box technique that
has successfully toilet trained cats for
decades
you can be part of that club bud it
starts as a litter box that you put
underneath the seat of your toilet and
then it gradually has less litter until
it's just the toilet
i'm so sorry
today it starts ready
here you are
this is cool isn't it you love this
everything's great
oh my gosh that's not wonderful wait
come here
this way
oh
that did not go as planned oh my gosh
it's gonna go terribly my hope is that
he'll kind of recognize it a little bit
more as a litter box so i put him on
there and he was kind of playing with it
but then i don't really know how to
reward him i try to give him a treat
while he's on there but then he's like
eating where he shits or he's supposed
to [ __ ] and then the treat falls in the
litter box i don't want him to eat the
litter but then if he jumps off i'm not
sure if i'm like rewarding him to jump
off
i don't know but i feel like we might be
making like even the slightest bit of
progress so here's
his toilet
and you swoop on down
and here's a nice piece of litter that
he kicked that's on our door let's just
look at the distance
[Music]
for that
i hopped into my car
i see a text from alex my fiance
and it's just a picture of the toilet
with litter everywhere and like some of
the cat had
knocked his poop out to the ground the
cat was like
embarrassed
then he ran into the bathroom so i
followed him in there
and he was like
i look over and just like cat litter's
everywhere do you think this is going to
be worth it in the end
no i absolutely i spent more time
cleaning his litter up than i've ever
seen cleaning litter
all the other time combined but you
wouldn't have to clean the letter after
like once he starts using it
what if he never learns oh my god
the cat
i'm sorry
he's so not happy you [ __ ] on our bed
and i don't know why i'm laughing
because it's not funny it's actually
really upsetting and it's like a like
angry poop you know like he does not
feel good
i feel like a really bad cat mom he's so
embarrassed
this is obviously upsetting him i think
he ruined our quote
he's refueling for round two
i'm stoked because today we are talking
to a co-worker's dad who is both a
veterinarian and a cat trainer i'm
hoping that he can help me determine if
this is right for chester i'm sydney the
one with the cat what have been your
problems the problem that we're having
is litter's always all over our bathroom
i just feel so bad for my cat moving the
litter box changing the litter all those
things
potentially frustrate a cat much less
putting it in the toilet i think you
just have to go really slow
with the hole make it really you know
make it really really tiny do you think
that i'll be successful in this
oh sure yeah i i i'm impressed with how
far you've gone no i feel good i
impressed the cat trainer good luck i
just walked through the door and i'm
greeted by
this man who says
go look at the cat's box
chester
what's wrong with you
that's not even part of your litter box
you literally pooped on the
on the toilet seat oh no
yesterday alex surprised me by getting a
self-cleaning litter box because that
was originally why i wanted to train the
cat was so that we didn't have to clean
the litter while i am pretty bummed that
we don't have a cat that's using the
toilet and i feel bad that i have taken
him and alex through this journey with
me i'm happy with a robot litter box
that's okay with me i guess he just
wasn't meant to be toilet trained he's
not gonna learn chester how do you like
your new litter box
[Music]
you